[Music]
and Karma's a [ __ ] news
I don't like Karma there's only a [ __ ]
if you're a [ __ ] to her Karma's pretty
hot isn't she is she I think anymore why
are you staying at Karma good name karma
talk cool just nice ball like Kylie
Karma's cool cuz if you [ __ ] her she
[ __ ] you back isn't that a good thing
yeah oh that's why she's hot
that is not submitted by Jo Molly and
dog walker that was my thing
you're know one thing a man is fine 120
million by the FCC after being charged
for making 100 million robo calls in
three months I was a robo call like a
prank call you get a phone call
and it's like hi you're look for [ __ ]
Ted Stephen oh [ __ ]
this unit fined for that I thought that
I mean how come people can do that cuz I
get those we're we're actually not
supposed to get those on our cell phone
it's illegal
yeah well all these fans yeah you get
caught if you could catch up we could
really put the picture I get one from a
San Diego cruise line thing like every
other day yeah so that's kind of what he
was doing so grabbing sister so have you
guys gotten phone number or phone calls
from numbers that have the first six
digits of your number
yes yeah oh yeah always called neighbor
spoofing so that's illegal and I
supposed to be doing that yeah I
definitely get that also you go oh this
is somebody I might know because it's
like my number yeah you're like oh it's
a childhood friend and that's why I'm
like I don't have any childhood friends
I'm not picking up the phone so I get
calls where it's from a different number
like it gets it from like a six one nine
number like some area code I've never
heard of and then right after that is my
area code with the numbers and I'm like
oh that's why I don't pick up the phone
strangers everybody that I know is all
in yeah and then they tell me to if it's
like a number that I don't know they go
it's maybe job I love
marzo oh it's maybe it's a smartphone
yeah so the FCC finalized its largest
robocalling fine in history
against this man named Adrian Abramovich
who lives in Florida yeah finest ass I
agree with this yeah I like this about
my [ __ ] a hundred and twenty million
dollar fine find another job damn it so
he's made that much money for a little
spam calls apparently he made almost a
hundred million okay
don't find another job that shit's good
no yeah you gotta find a hundred twenty
million so we know he's 20 no way do I
become a robo caller yeah how do I get
this set up what we do anyone can do it
apparent lot same because it's a [ __ ]
application you guys this is bad stuff
what's bad about it if you're making 100
million she's a couple of phone calls
the day you got 520 those days 20
million in the hole why does this cat
okay so he just gonna catch noggin time
yeah 120 million dollars of damages for
people go on like it might be meaning
that doesn't make sense he treats old
people exactly he made uh almost a
hundred million dollars off of tricking
old people into like timeshare why are
they so trickable then yeah why are they
so easily took a bowl Oh be more
supposed to be wiser than those teaching
us from sugar ball they know everything
Florida so Rob Lowe retirement community
oh it's all over the country who was
calling but he just based in Florida
based in Florida
[ __ ] man and you know how old people
can't resist timeshare they can't resist
a deal love it that's where it is they
need a deal I know yeah the way that
they trick them is by doing that
neighbor spoofing thing and so elderly
people they're most like they're more
likely to answer the phone call because
they're lonely it's true man because
this all this technology is moving so
fast that they can't keep up with
learning that oh my phone's ringing
calling me hello they put all their
glasses is it my son
no okay well this sounds like a fine
young man like that kind of yeah and so
it'll be like an automated message and
sometimes like they'll make it sound
like it's an actual person because they
have these algorithms now that can
actually respond to the person whenever
they ask them something then they'll
have like a set an automated response
yeah oh it's like an AI type of like
exactly and so they're able to them
they're able to handle like millions of
phone calls at once like these programs
oh yeah so that's why we're always
constantly getting these robo calls and
so a lot of these so once they start
speaking to that machine and they ask
some questions and then they respond and
then they'll lead them to a an actual
human operator who then tries to sell
them these fake timeshares and and then
they end up realizing that it was fake
but then they lost that money so they
try to go after them and so all these
major companies cuz they're trying to
say like it's actual big hotel lines
like for example like Hilton or whatever
they're saying like oh yeah you can come
stay at our resort over here for a
discounted rate and so but then by the
time they actually talk to that human
then that human is trying to sell them
timeshares in Mexico and stuff Liars I
feel I feel bad for these old people
cause I used to call them I just forgot
this mortgage company and then I would
call these all people and they're like
damn and you call me do you know what
time it is it's 6:30 yeah I'm so sorry
sir Oh what are you having um I don't
name balls they just open them up like
that but they're all people they're just
so easily swim gullible even though
they're so thirsty for that attention
yeah their grandkids and [ __ ] kids
don't don't visit leave him for dead man
they really do one thing [ __ ] up
one time I helped this lady refinance a
home and she had nine homes well so I
cashed in big on that one cuz all he was
talking about that one but she wanted
that she wanted to talk so much she gave
me all like each other property ah so
what else do you own what else Depot and
what else do you that was like a gold
mine she couldn't wait get away I'm rich
[ __ ] yeah I got nine refight
nine properties damn
that's sad you guys should call your
grandparents they need love good but
that [ __ ] will forget they were alive
you can't talk to them for 24 hours a
day right like the day it's lonely like
no matter what even if you call him and
check in like it then then they hang up
the phone and they sit there and that's
what's sad for me they watch TV if they
get a smile and then they're a little
bit more resistant when that weird
number comes and they pick up you
already talked to my grandson you all
[ __ ] see but they always it always like
they always call right and it's always
like you want a thing yeah the winning
thing is the one that tricks people
they're like oh right and then then it
can be like you want a discount on the
timeshare you've won a cruise ship thing
but you have to pay us for the tickets
shipping the tickets is 300 where you
won this thing but you have to show up
to the timeshare meeting at this address
exactly exactly make these old people a
little bit just take away smarter than
how are they not skeptical though
because I was raised to be very
skeptical that's how I was like old
people it [ __ ] Publishers Clearing
House came to my door with a big check
all right open the door and be like no
this is a scam enclosed yeah and they'd
have cameras there and everything and I
just don't buy it
I don't believe any of that [ __ ] ever
dad do we smarten these old people up so
don't get scared
yeah cuz when we used to get the spam
mails and [ __ ] my grandma proved to me
that [ __ ] was fake cuz I was like look
he says we could have won something yeah
and then she was like whoa I'll sign up
for it and I'll show you that's not
gonna work
oh that's cool came in and then I'm like
to him I got I got had what we should do
is a service that helps old people and
we reach a robocall then charge them for
our service to protect them from the
scammers Oh people mom person that signs
up their friend they get a cut sign of a
cub protection racket pyramid scheme
it's actually all people Union you got a
rebrand and call it a union and we
protect you from scammers yep reunion
we're anti scammed Amazon the Mafia
that's right I think they can't resist
picking up the phone though listen are
you guys in or not cuz this dealer spire
like at the end of this video I'm in I
mean I mean if we're really gonna
protect open you guys at the scam don't
listen to him with the stance yeah but
you listen to him you may be a scam
you're not I bet okay so if the hundred
million is are in is in our our hands I
think we could better protect them than
anybody give us 100 million but we're
gonna get fine the 120 mil no we're
human we're protecting them whose side
are you on I'm on the legal side
yeah but we're making it legal we're
gonna figure something out
it's gonna be we're just launder it make
it legal we'll go to Vegas you launder
it through the tables we all know this
we all know the game
it's like Norton AntiVirus but for your
phone yep it sounds like half of you are
doing it legally the other half is
sounds illegal no that's gonna protect
the old people okay and then when people
try to scam up well call them back and
say [ __ ] you that's it yeah and then we
taught them we charges old people and
what we'll filter we're pretty much
phone shelter hey this is your grandson
oh you know what this guy's a [ __ ] face
yeah and then we're charging them to
beat the phone filter and all these
millions of calls will get a robo
service yeah that handles these millions
of calls too because whole robot starts
talking to a robot the robot will pick
up like hello there was a guy that I
thought like Hugh made headlines like he
actually used an algorithm to span the
telemarketers and then so they were just
holding up the phone lines like the
whole time that's beautiful I love that
kind of trolling that's see that's what
we're gonna do yeah that's time our
robots gonna have a seat senior voice
hello yeah so the robot thinks it's
[ __ ] with someone yeah what if the
robot is like oh I'm gonna pay in just a
second and then it come up with other
questions anyone a human comes up like
they just waste their time oh that's
right that's funny
hold on a second I'm bout to give the
guy a car on prices right hold on a sec
right and then you hear like Dan the
guy's like sitting on hold like yes
repeated multiple times yeah or it's an
expiration date this is 17 2017 they'll
be done yeah that's kind of a thing I
wouldn't I mean that's cool apparently
according to this article here that
there is open source software available
for anyone to start the robocall
[ __ ]
yeah but they need advertisers very true
it's like this guy's out of your
competition yeah all right
what if we Robo called people positive
messages like you're doing great you're
very special and you're gonna do well
the knife or some [ __ ] that I would say
about making money tip your [ __ ]
capital in sign up for it I didn't give
you all my money because I just need
some validation yeah see it's a robot
daddy issues
you won a surprise message and you could
pick the voice you could pick it for
like a male voice like a dad voice a mom
voice it's gonna sound like a champion
like I'm just calling to say that you're
important or something feel like you
could give a sample of your parents
voice so that at least sounds like
they're telling damn Nicky just needs
Nick he just needs her dad to tell her
that she loves her but it'll never
[ __ ] happen you leave me alone stop
it
[Music]